love this guy i love his uh analysis on
espn worldwide leader in sports and also
uh when he does games with iron eagle
for the nets it's just terrific richard
jefferson back on the rich eisen show
how are you richard jefferson what's
going on i am great rich man thank you
so much for having me you bet so uh i i
this is crazy i mean the world is nuts
the world is not is really not many
times i don't begin interviews by saying
the world is totally nuts but the world
is nuts and i think once again the nba
is at the forefront of what's going on
in society that i i fully believe that
there was a shutdown back
in uh march of 2020 for the the country
that uh was more understood
understandable for everybody because the
nba took the step and uh i'm wondering
what you think of what the nba is up to
right now these days richard well i i
think right now there's there's probably
a lot of confusion
um because you know a lot of the people
that are testing negative are testing
positive excuse me are asymptomatic so
it was it's you know i think there was a
less regulation of testing if you were a
vaccinated player so they weren't
getting vaccinated and then when i think
things started going or not they weren't
getting tested as much
so then when things started going crazy
and they started up things upping
testing
they started realizing that everyone had
it and i'm not literally everyone but
40 of the guys you know probably had it
of the people that have been tested
and and that put the indiana spot of hey
what do we do do i think a shutdown or a
bubble is coming
no could there be a possible break
maybe but ultimately i think a lot of it
has more do with like you know getting
to christmas day that's such a huge day
for the nba and it's only five days away
um you know but i i think right now it's
more about like regulating upping the
testing making sure guys are getting
booster shots stuff like that but yes it
is very very crazy and it's not just
it's not just um the nba it's all sports
right now but i i i'm curious this is
how they proceed you're right the nhl is
thinking about pausing through christmas
day right now they have a big decision
about what whether or not to uh send
their players to the beijing olympics
that's supposed to come today the nfl
has totally changed the way that they
were planning on testing vaccinated
players now and
um you know it's just like i said a
crazy mixed up world and then the and
the nets and the lakers are scheduled to
play eight eastern time on uh on
christmas night and i know we want to
look we're starting to dig into these
games but before we do uh were you
surprised that the nets reversed on
kyrie and said uh sure we'll take you
for half the season after all
um
i think a little bit of
a little bit of surprise uh i think most
people from a team aspect you know in
the nba and in the media
in the media space understood why they
said no it's hard to it's hard enough to
win a championship everything's got to
go in your favor and when you add that
continuity aspect
you know of not having a player for home
games imagine if you're forced into a
game seven and now you're going to ask
uh you're going to ask you know uh a
person you know kyrie to not play in a
game seven on the road you know like we
know the biggest show on the biggest
shot in nba history was hit by him in a
game seven on the road so we can't say
like statistically that that might not
happen so uh but i think now when you're
seeing that there's so many players that
are in and out so many players that are
testing positive so much of this stuff
is going on that you're kind of thinking
like yo all hands are on deck at the end
of the day like we our job is to help
ourselves win a game and help ourselves
position ourselves for the postseason
and i think it's difficult as is but i
think adding kyrie in this moment uh i i
think does make more sense than it
doesn't okay when you're talking about
playing you know guys like david duke jr
when you're talking about playing guys
like kessler 25 minutes to get through a
season
and everyone's going to be cool with it
and then the nets can can handle it
right like
that's not that's not for us to
determine you know that for the players
and i think the players would welcome
him i think the biggest thing that
people need to understand is this was
not a nba rule this was not a nets rule
the vaccine is a city mandate right so
any frustration should and i shouldn't
say frustration but any questions
should be directed at the team not the
nba like there are other players that
are unvaccinated they just aren't
playing in the new york tri-state area
which was one of the hardest hit with
kovit right so you understand why they
are ultra cautious if he was playing in
houston this would not be an issue so
it's more of the location than it is you
know the teams and and his teammates
richard jefferson here on the rich eisen
show from uh from espn yes network and
more so let's let's jump into it man uh
i sure hope that jordan poole and uh and
andrew wiggins
can come off of their covet list and uh
and nobody else gets it obviously
between now and then and that the suns
come in nice and healthy to warriors
sons they have been some fun games to
watch already this year i know devin
booker hurt himself in one of them and
the sun still won it
um i'm so looking forward to that one
on saturday
yeah i think people underestimate this
phoenix team like go back and look at
the postseason and we can talk about
chris paul obviously is having another
all-nba quality season but go back and
look at that postseason last year they
won games they closed out a team without
chris paul like that think about how
hard that is to lose arguably your most
important player or most veteran player
during a playoff run especially with all
the young players chris paul missed a
couple of games and that and that
phoenix sun team still went out there
and won playoff games so to me you know
when i look at this phoenix suns versus
golden state warriors i don't care if
it's chris paul out there if devin
booker's not there that team and monty
williams has that team playing such a
unique and together brand of basketball
that it's just you know whoever they put
out there i think it's going to be a
quality game obviously we hope everyone
is healthy but even regardless if
there's one or two key players in this
missing i still think it's going to be
an amazing game well i mean your name
comes up often around here richard uh
because you were one of the many but you
were definitely the one who cut the
deepest a couple years ago when i said
that the i have my opinion here uh on
the show that the heat fresh off of
finishing second in the bubble should
not break up their team if giannis was
made available um your reaction was
priceless telling me i didn't know jack
about it um i'm just paraphrasing you
were much kinder about that um so your
name comes up here often uh so i'm i
have to mention uh that i i do believe i
found the antidote which was my
pre-season prediction the warriors who
were going to win the championship how
about that
i like that that that is that is so much
better than not thank you for 20 26 or
27 year old giannis onto the goomba like
it's kind of like the people that were
like i saw some tweets the other day
when people were like you know oh now
that the cavs are good like braun you
listen braun we do not want lebron james
to come in here and mess it's like shut
up anyone that says that don't talk to
me oh it didn't work out well the last
time you didn't like going to four or
five straight finals you didn't like
that shut up if if lebron james showed
up and said he's changing the name to
the lebronets cleveland deal with it
because you're going to be excited at
the result um but yeah i i think the
golden state warriors have done an
outstanding job of adding some veterans
uh bringing back andre iguodala but the
development you cannot account you
cannot discount the amount of
development that's going on with jordan
poole toscano anderson we we're all
waiting to see um you know what
um god what's the big fella's name you
haven't played all this here yeah wise
wiseman's going to bring to the table
you know you hope that he can have a
development similar to deandre ayton
where he's a great roller possible throw
into the post space guy but the warriors
have every component i will say it
concerns me a smidge that they were
planning on having klay thompson
available probably a week or so before
christmas day so he would play maybe one
or two christmas day game or one or two
games and then play on christmas day and
now they've pushed it back to january so
not saying that they were like a hard
set date and he's regressed but it's
like
he's been out for two years he's been
you know training now for seven eight
months building up and now they push it
in a month so you know i hope that you
know there's no you know lingering
effects and that that he hasn't
regressed any in his timetable well
they're like that we're 25 and six
there's no rush you know what i mean and
you can use you could use
january february games to get them up to
speed and then by the time april hits
off you go you know yeah um and and i
just love watching them play they're so
self selfless
you know and they're they're they're not
selfish
and i just i just love that draymond you
know is still a guy that so many things
run through
and there's nobody that gary payton ii
will not try to dunk on you know
and i i just love watching him play i
just think it's just terrific it's great
bob myers has done an outstanding job
like again we talk about that
development but like gary payton ii has
been he's been in the league right
people make it seem like he's a 28 year
old guy and everyone knows his dad so
it's not like this guy was flying under
the radar but sometimes you get a guy
and it's like oh he fit not only does he
fit with us he excels with us he's not a
shooter he's not he's not necessarily
scored but he's a hellish athlete and a
ridiculous aggressive defender that's
what you need you're like we need as
many talented smalls that we could look
we got enough shooting with steph and
jordan and clay and you know we got
enough shooting right you can even go
with wiggins and and uh and otto porter
we got enough shooting who's going to
come out here that's going to be a dog
on a defensive end and i i think you see
that he brings that so if you've got
three shooters four shooters on the
floor and him even though he's not a
great shooter like that team has such
beautiful balance and the thing that i
love the most is that two things one
steph is the biggest encourager of all
of these young guys like he is cheering
on the bench he's jumping up and down
and two all of these guys want to see
steph succeed so there is no
i want to get mine they're like oh
steph's got it going fire it up steph
fire it up let's go let's get them
screens let's do this stuff and it took
a while i think for those young players
in the last couple of years to learn how
to play a movement style ball with steph
but now that they figured out they are
dominating so warriors and sons uh again
at five eastern time right in the middle
of the day um we're knocking on wood
that it's gonna stay the same and then
you know you've got the nets at lakers
mavericks at the jazz you're doing that
broadcast at 10 30 p.m eastern time
lakers or jazz for a third team in to
crash the suns warriors party here which
one do you think is more likely
richard jefferson
i think more likely today we would
obviously say the utah jazz i think the
lakers just can't they've been trying to
get right they've been trying to get
their their you know their their rhythm
their flow their confidence they're just
missing so many guys and we saw this
isn't uh last year probably kind of
dispelled that rumor of let's just get
to the postseason healthy and then we'll
just out you know talent other teams
where phoenix and golden state play a
brand of basketball that like if you're
not if you're not pumping at a high
level of continuity on the offensive end
on the defensive end and communicating
all they're going to eat you alive
they're going to eat you alive and so
that worries me that anthony davis i did
the game where he got hurt i was doing
the game of beth mowins in minnesota and
at first it was a rolled ankle and again
anybody that wants a question anthony
davis's toughness i get it what whatever
but both of those things would have
taken out any player
when someone throws and your knee just
hypers extend i don't care who you are
if you're standing in that spot you're
going to miss some time so there's been
some unluckiness when it comes to them
but it's just hard for me to say that
right now with him missing a month
lebron is going to be up but his minutes
are going to be high russ needs anthony
so he can get his rhythm as a roll and
replace guy and it's just right now
they're just in such disarray and not
necessarily because of their fault yeah
it seems like the lakers uh might be uh
or might be in in line for a second
straight state farm playing game you
know what i'm saying oh i saw that i saw
they're in the plan right now and it
doesn't help that their schedule over
the next two thirds of the season or or
the
final two third of the season is one of
the more difficult now i think that that
could be a good thing because some of
these dudes need to stop showing up like
oh we're going to figure it out and it's
like no you need to kind of light a
little fire under their asses and and
and get them pumping um
so i you know hopefully being in the
fire and playing against high level
competition and these guys kind of you
know these veterans being put in you
know with their backs against the wall i
believe that they will show up if their
backs are against the wall but you still
don't want to be the sixth or fifth seed
and have having to play a phoenix a utah
in the first round you don't want that
that's who you want to play in this in
in the second round in the conference
finals because you're building in but if
you talk about one two and three one two
and three are complete from offense the
defense they're complete from depth
they're complete from position players
so if you're talking about three of the
most complete teams in the league in
phoenix golden state in utah that played
consistent basketball and then you're
looking at the lakers and you're looking
at other teams dallas those teams are on
the outside looking in it's those three
and everybody else currently last one
for you richard uh you're you're you're
uh a straight talker uh you've proven it
in this interview again you do it all
the time on television tj jefferson my
social media grand maester philadelphia
76ers die hard uh you want to talk to
him about his desire to get damian
lillard on the sixers and the
possibilities yeah yeah yeah tj yes sir
okay what's up partner
hey what's up my guy it ain't happening
it ain't happening i i i'm i'm resigning
that fact i gave you are you there you
are you really don't just fold don't
just fold like that i think i said this
a while back when dame came out and said
he didn't want to leave i was like look
man i can offer you the riches
and if you decide not to take him then
what can i do like i'm offering you the
most
physically gifted big man of his
generation to play with he doesn't want
him so what am i supposed to do no no
but you got to understand you got to
understand this because he's under
contract because he's under contract i'm
going to make an argument to say that uh
the highest bidder might not this is
dame lillard in the prime of his career
under contract with the ability to sign
a two-year extension dame lillard i
don't know if the highest offer if the
highest offer was going would be
uh uh what philly could offer i don't
know if like oh ben simmons and maxie
and so and so and so so-and-so and maybe
a couple of picks and this i don't know
if that would be the best offer like i
know ben simmons we can say what we want
about him but like been that might not
be the best offer out there imagine if
boston decided to jump in imagine if
some of these other teams that have some
high level players wanted to adjust
the portland trailblazers are going to
do what's best for them not say hey dan
thank you for your service we're going
to send you to philly and whatever
philly will send back will take see i
was hoping that's what was going to
happen like in my mind that's how this
whole thing was going to go down he'd be
like hey we'll give you this it'll be
like okay fine take them and then just
to make me happy well using that logic
using that logic think about how the how
the the value for ben simmons has
changed right yesterday's price is not
today's price exactly so it's like
they're asking for this this and this
for multiple players and it's like same
thing happened a couple years ago with
james harden there was talks about him
in philly they were talked about him in
boston and the only team that showed up
and was willing to give x y and z was
the brooklyn net and trust me if you
think that that didn't you know maybe
danny ainge decided to go a different
direction if you don't think that daryl
mori might have been a little frustrated
that the fact that they could have
gotten james harden
like the brooklyn nets were like hey if
if they don't want to come off of it
this will give you a better offer than
all of them and so you gotta people need
to understand that just because there is
a trade situation possible in philly
that portland will accept that as the
best offer possible well i mean boston
you mentioned boston you're not you're
just saying not tatum but tatum would
say here's my number zero or something
like that is that what you're saying i i
there was some discussions about james
harden in boston there was some
discussion about james harden in philly
heavy discussions whether it was jaylen
brown whether it was you know sending
you know a ton of spending a bunch of
sending ben simmons sending ben simmons
in uh and there was conversation and
they all fell flat because they felt
like the asking price was too high and
then all of a sudden that asking price
is looking a lot better right now i know
james harden hasn't had a great season
but you would just think that oh if you
had a healthy james harden and you had
um you know adjacent tatum or had james
harden with with ben simmons or with
with joel embiid you would have a
monster but just because the house is
for sale doesn't mean that you always
often have the right buyers richard
jefferson thanks again uh happy holidays
merry christmas safe travel let's do
this again in the new year please i
always appreciate you i'm sorry tj you
guys are still good i mean you guys are
still good you gotta you gotta you got
an akeem elijah one level player out
there and and joel a bead but you gotta
find that clyde drexler to be next to
him exactly how many you you got 10 12
minutes left
no no no no no they offered they offered
in brooklyn i'm just kidding
[Laughter]
but no no no i'm good all right well
thanks for ruining my christmas no stop
and he'll make up for it with a great
call of uh mavericks uh
true to wrap up the uh the quintuple
header thanks again for the call richard
you'd be well
all right thank you richard jefferson at
rjf24 on twitter richard a jefferson on
instagram hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here